et alors les cherry en ce moment il ya
une personne autour de la table
qui est décriée par ses petits camarades
ah bon oui
cette personne c'est une personne
qu a failli se suicider dans de la neige
cj bernès verdez c'est vrai que je sais
pas ce qui se passe avec va tous vous
êtes très agitée envers vos petits
camarades ont dû y aller et même sur les
réseaux les téléspectateurs ont fait
savoir si le dernier est un malade
mental de fer soit
oui voilà bon pour rendre justice à vos
camarades
puisqu'on vous dit que vous leur couper
beaucoup la parole de vérité dur avec
eux mais pour moi le meilleur élève de
la classe
pour du style à vos camarades chacun
d'entre eux aura 20 secondes pour dire
ce qu'ils pensent de vous
et en retour j'ai une vous aurez 20
secondes vous en tout pour dire ce que
vous pensez de l'enfant
pourront choisir un ou deux
voiliers c'est ce que
alors on va démarrer par bernard montiel
alors pour moi j'ai leverdez c'est le
jeff pana clock de jean-marc du jackman
acloque c'est à dire que c'est le jean
marc de cyril end là à dire qu'il y ait
ce que vous voulez entendre ah oui alors
rions n'est jamais d'accord
ça ne paie pas
on change direct à leroy lui répondre
les drôles
vous venez faire la meilleure semaine de
votre vie donc
on s'est tu sur un yacht à saint tropez
vous avez brillé par votre absence donc
ma question à l'éclair qu'est ce que
vous foutez ici
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ou aller que je sait mettre l'ambiance
valérie médaille alors mongil pour moi
tu es une personnalité à quatre visages
pas un pas deux pas trois quatre quand
tu es d'accord avec les gens tu as bois
premier visage quand tu n'es pas
d'accord du braille deuxième visage
quand tu as un argument a donné tu
hurles troisième visage et quand tu n'as
rien à dire tu gueules quatrième visage
résultats aux femmes tu casse les
oreilles au mec tu casses les couilles
[Applaudissements]
aux hommes du casse les oreilles aux
violences kasraoui et là ils nous
avaient changé ouais ouais j'suis trop
ça rigolo ça va les couilles de patoche
québec
on embrasse voulu répondre brièvement
sur wii ma chère valérie
et fonça défenseur selim et des prime
xxl en faisant des audiences xxs
prochain
j'ai dû
alors c'est terminé on répond plus aux
réponses et voilà il fait des fonds mais
tu es tombé d'accord ça actu la casser
les couilles
allez monsieur perdu ardennes
[Musique]
j'ai rencontré beaucoup beaucoup d'un
poster dans ma vie et un te décerne la
palme de la posture
ça s'arrête tout
savoir et las vegas et normalement il
veut rien je réponds pas non c'est pas
[Rires]
d'accord delphine alors moi je vais un
peu te redonner de l'énergie c'est
encore avec moi il est formidable je
trouve que tu es formidable tu n'est
absolument jamais d'accord avec personne
et justement c'est ça qui me plaît ce
soir tu n'es pas un mouton tu défends
telle idée même si parfois tu es de
mauvaise foi même si je ne suis jamais
d'accord avec toi mais ce que j'aime
chez toi c'est que quand tu as une idée
là et quand tu as une idée là tu
l'expriment malgré et anvers contre tout
sans la toucher attendez pas à ça c'est
bien voulu quand même j'espère que tu as
préparé pour moi du coup non non je te
réponds pas décrocher un boulot votre
gentil quand même nom mé li scud a
marqué sur des fiches plus tôt c'était
moyennement gentil
vous voulez on sait qu'on a roulé alors
je pense de ce que tu as plus conscience
de ce que tu as pris part à la soirée
c'est vrai non il avait alors eu à 0
conviction le gaming jaurès à ce que
j'avais préparé et sinon tu découvres
hainard
c'est gentil mais s'il joue ce qui vient
d'ici et ce qui vient de la sq au chili
à tous mes
messages avec finn vous fait remarquer
par vos interventions pertinentes par
votre splendeur voilà le brio de vos
arguments mais jamais sur le plateau
donc
attention dans les jambes
c'est gentil alors moi pour moi gilles
c'est docteur jekyll et mister tarbes a
c'est à dire que en loge il est à doha
mais le plus gentil me dire tu veux un
café aux tubes rien arrangé bon comme tu
es gentil et à et en plateau il dépend
dé la girouette
surexcités ces deux personnalités ouais
voilà un peu fou complètement fou
francesca
huit ans que vous êtes chroniqueuse à
touche pas à mon poste et en six mois
clément gard a fait plus des missions
que vous
[Applaudissements]
allez génial balle au fil des fois je me
régale
les défend souvent l'indéfendable je
suis souvent contre toi j'aimerais mieux
être contre toi mais bon bon alors
résumé la pensée de tout le monde tu es
un sacré gros bouffons et gros bator
quand passe machart daniel va plus vous
radotez plus vous me soul et à la pub
plus j'ai l'impression d'avoir isabella
côté de moi alors serré le temps qu'elle
revienne
ça va ça vient vraiment à l'origine moi
je suis pas je suis pas delphine je vais
pas de cirer les pompes je suis pas
française car je veux pas parler de
girouette je pense que tu as un gros
problème un gros problème de
personnalité que même n'importe quel
médecin dans paris peut pas t'aider
c'était complètement givrée les débats
tu dois pas les lire avant tu ne tu
parles tu parles tu pas et quand tu
parles montante en plus tu parles plus
tu longe les murs donc je pense que tu
as un gros problème hormis le fait que
j'aime pas ton monte de sape et j'aime
pas ta dam de cheveux en gros je ne
t'aime pas c'est parce que tu fous là
pour autant de temps
est-ce que je peux me permettre avec
tout le respect
d'un conseil à raymond morey mon cher
ami vous devriez faire le soir ce que
vous faites en journée et vous en double
file et laisser les professionnels
[Applaudissements]
mais
elle est très bonne alors gier pour moi
tu es un mystère tu es limité un objet
télévisuel non identifié est souvent
dans la rue en m'arrête et on dit mais
dites-moi géraldine gilles verdez il est
sincère il est vraiment comme ça il
tente vraiment ce qui dit il a des
parents parfois des convictions à
géométrie variable donc en fait moi je
veux savoir vraiment ce soir qui est du
lot gilles verdez alors je vais vous
répondre très calmement à bout géraldine
parce que vous êtes quelqu'un de
particulier ici comme vous êtes une
intellectuelle
pariez pas c'est vrai
je vais citer un autre intellectuel
coluche disait vous avez un avis sur
tout vous avez surtout un avis sur les
vaccins sur le vote sur tout le monde
vous nous emmerdez depuis des années
vous êtes en fait une sorte de soeur de
myriam palombes à 25 ans
je me maquille dessus et je réponds pas
encore j'ai pas envie de vous re
je te plait je suis nerveux donc ça veut
partir à tout
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue il m'a prévenu que ça pourrait
dégénérer sur s'est passé on le fait
d'ailleurs comme cheryl womé schéma
serrant ses yeux
tu parles mal à tout le monde et plus
particulièrement un magot daniel pennac
moi bien je sais quoi toi et ta face de
ratatouille vous parlez encore une fois
à ma meuf de la sorte je réponds
favorablement aux avances de fatou sur
kinder
elle sert guillaume vous connaissez le
dicton plus on a une grosse bagnole plus
on veut cacher sa petite-fille gouny
[Applaudissements]
bien vu que j'étais venu ans marc
parfois tu es su souvent vélo
merci mais ça fait du bien dit
videz votre sackboy
vois que tu parles
savez ça fait du bien ça mais on pourra
faire ça pour tout bien sûr maintenant
veiller à ce que gilles est il vraiment
perturbateur est détesté par les élèves
adoré par le moment
ces femmes souvent ça vous auriez
préféré le contraire non non je suis
très bien comme ça
vous avez raison